- [Man] This episode of LegalEagle
was made possible by Skillshare.
Learn to think like a lawyer
for free for two months
by clicking on the link
in the description.
♪ Don't care how I want it now ♪
- Yeah, that is manslaughter
bordering on negligent homicide.
A jury would convict
Willy Wonka like that.
Hey Legal Eagles it's time
to think like a lawyer.
Today I am very excited to start
a brand new series on this channel
where I examine your
favorite fictional works
to tell you all of the
laws that have been broken
during the course of
that movie or TV show.
Today we're gonna start things off
by examining one of my
favorite childhood movies
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory.
Let's see if I can ruin your childhood
as much as law school ruined mine.
Be sure to stick around until the end
where I give you my verdict
as to how much money Willy Wonka owes
and how long he's going to jail.
A little background about myself,
I have been a practicing
lawyer for over 10 years.
I am admitted to the bar in five states
including the District of Columbia.
I have handled hundreds
of millions of dollars worth of cases
both on the plaintiff
and the defense side.
And in my spare time, when I have any
I teach law students how
to kick ass in law school.
- I serve all his TV dinners right here.
He's never even been to the table.
- So I am imminently qualified
to examine a work of fiction
to tell you all of the
laws that it has broken.
So without further ado let's dig in
to Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory.
- [Charlie] Hi Mr. Jopeck.
- [Mr. Jopeck] Ah, come
along Charlie you're late.
- [Charlie] It's pay day Mr. Jopeck.
- [Mr. Jopeck] You're
right, there you are.
- Thanks.
- Say hello to your Grandpa Joe.
- Okay.
- Okay big problem right off the bat.
Charlie is way too young
to have a paper route.
I think this is a child labor violation.
Here this is governed by
the Federal Labor Standards Act or FLSA
which states that no
one under the age of 14
can hold a job in the United States.
So later on in this movie,
Mike TV actually mentions
that he's 12 years old.
And because I think all the children
are supposed to be exactly the same age
I think Charlie is clearly
under the age of 14.
Therefore while Mr. Jopeck here
may be thinking he is doing a good thing
he's actually committing
a child labor violation.
♪ Oompa Loompa do ba dee doo ♪
- What's happening?
- Willy Wonka's opening his factory.
He's gonna let people in.
- You sure?
- It's on the radio
and he's giving truckloads
of chocolate away.
- [Teacher] Class dismissed!
- [Boy] No, no it's only for five people.
- Class undismissed.
- He's hidden five golden tickets
and the people who find
'em will win the big prize.
- Where's he hidden the tickets?
- Inside five Wonka Bars.
You gotta buy Wonka Bars to find 'em.
- [Teacher] Class redismissed!
- Okay big problem here.
This is a clear violation
of sweepstakes law
that exists in most states.
You might notice that whenever
you see a giveaway on TV
there's always some fine print that says
no purchase necessary.
There is a very, very
good reason for that.
The reason is, if you require purchase
you're no longer a free
giveaway in a sweepstakes
you are an illegal lottery.
That's the difference
between gambling in a lottery
and a sweepstakes which
is just a giveaway.
That's why you always hear
that no purchase is necessary
and you can participate in the giveaway
without actually making a purchase.
Willy Wonka has not added that language
and he explicitly requires
you to buy his chocolate bars
in order to participate
in the golden ticket hunt.
That is a clear violation
of sweepstakes law
and my guess is that
he would be on the hook
for the millions of dollars
that people have spent
buying Wonka Bars in order to participate
in this particular sweepstakes.
♪ If you're not greedy you will go far ♪
- I want it now!
What's the matter with
those twerps down there?
- For five days now the
entire flipping factory's
been on the job.
They haven't shelled a
peanut in there since Monday.
They've been shelling
flaming chocolate bars
from dawn to dusk.
- Make 'em work nights!
- Come along, come along you girls.
Put a jerk in it or
you'll be out on your ears
every one of ya!
And listen to this!
The first girl that finds a golden ticket
gets a one pound bonus in your pay packet!
What do you think of that?
- Alright that is another FLSA violation.
He is clearly pushing his
staff far, far too hard.
They're working for five days straight
form dawn until dusk.
He's making them work overtime
without paying them anything extra.
That is a clear violation.
That's called a wage and hour violation.
I have friends who specialize
in these kind of wage and hour violations
under the FLSA.
And they will tell you that the
damages in this kind of case
really, really start to add up
because not only do you
have to pay them back pay
for all the extra work that they have done
but you're probably gonna
have to pay them overtime.
And on top of it you're
gonna pay statutory damages.
So for the thousands of workers
that this man has in his factory
he's gonna be on the hook
for hundreds of thousands
if not millions of dollars
in wage and hour violations.
Not good.
♪ Oompa Loompa do ba dee dee ♪
- May I introduce myself?
Oslo Slugworth,
president of Slugworth
Chocolates, Incorporated.
Now listen carefully
because I'm going to make
you very rich indeed.
Mr. Wonka is at this moment
working on a fantastic invention
the Everlasting Gobstopper.
If he succeeds he'll ruin me.
So all I want you to do is to get hold
of just one Everlasting Gobstopper
and bring it to me so that I
can find the secret formula.
Your reward will be 10,000 of these.
- Alright, so what Slugworth
is trying to do here
is engage in corporate espionage,
basically trying to steal a trade secret.
If the gobstopper had
been publicly released
then there would be nothing
that could stop Slugworth
from just simply buying one
and trying to reverse engineer
the Everlasting Gobstopper.
However since the Everlasting Gobstopper
has not been publicly released
it still probably qualifies
as a trade secret under Willy Wonka.
So by asking Charlie to find
an Everlasting Gobstopper
and bring it back to Slugworth
he's essentially asking Charlie
to engage in a conspiracy
to commit a trade secrets violation.
Now I know everyone's going to say,
"But Slugworth actually
works for Willy Wonka."
But here's the thing,
a conspiracy can have different mens rea
for different members of the conspiracy.
That's how you have a police officer
who engages in a conspiracy
who's not guilty of the conspiracies
all the other co-conspirators.
So you might get a weird situation
where Charlie has violated
the trade secrets act
by engaging in this conspiracy
while Slugworth has not.
♪ Oompa Loompa do ba da dee ♪
- Now, will the children
kindly step up here?
(man mumbling)
- [Man] Floods, fire, frost or frippery.
- [Mike TV] Accident,
what kinda accidents?
- [Woman] I didn't know
we had to sign anything
for this to work.
- [Violet] I can't see
what it says in the bottom.
- Violet, you first.
Sign here.
- Hold it.
Let me through here, you kids.
Violet baby, don't you
sign anything there.
What's this all about?
- Standard form of contract.
- Don't talk to me about
contracts Wonka I use 'em myself,
they're strictly for suckers.
- Yes, but you wouldn't
begrudge me a little protection.
A drop.
- I don't sign anything without my lawyer.
- [Mr. Salt] My Veruca
don't sign anything either.
- Then she don't go in.
I'm sorry, rules of the house.
- Okay, so Willy Wonka is
trying to get the children
to sign a liability waiver
to limit how much exposure he has
when things go terribly, terribly wrong.
Now, I probably don't
need to tell you that
if you can't physically read the contract
that's going to be problematic
for the person that's trying
to disclaim the liability.
That's called an unconscionable contract
that there is some procedural
or structural problem
with the contract itself
that makes it unconscionable
for the courts to enforce.
And if you can't physically see
the tiny print at the
bottom of this contract
that is a textbook
unconscionable contract.
But on top of that, Willy
Wonka's gonna have some problems
with signing a contract
with these children.
Only the children here have signed them.
They are minors.
The parents, while they are present
are not the ones signing this contract.
When a child signs a
contract, generally speaking,
that contract is voidable
at the option of the minor.
On top of that this contract
seems to be complete gibberish.
Generally speaking with
a limitation on liability
you can disclaim things like negligence
but you can almost never
disclaim recklessness.
This contract doesn't
appear to do any of that.
Maybe that's in the fine
print that no one can see.
But it appears to be just a
string of legal sounding words
that don't actually have any real meaning.
So I'm gonna go out on a limb
and say that Willy
Wonka has not disclaimed
any of his liability
and he's going to have
problems with civil suits
later on down the line for his
negligence and recklessness.
♪ What do you think will come of that ♪
- [Woman] What are they doing there?
- [Willy Wonka] Must be
creaming and sugaring time.
- [Violet] Well they can't be real people.
- [Willy Wonka] Well of
course they're real people.
- [Man] Stuff a nonsense.
- [Willy Wonka] No, Oompa Loompas.
- [Group] Oompa Loompas?
- [Willy Wonka] From Loompaland.
- Loompaland, there's no such place.
- Excuse me dear lady.
- Mr. Wonka, I am a teacher of geography.
- Oh, well then you now all about it
and what a terrible country it is.
Nothing but desolate
wastes and fierce beasts.
And the poor little Oompa Loompas
were so small and helpless
they would get gobbled up right and left.
A Wangdoodle would eat
10 of them for breakfast
and think nothing of it.
So I said, come and live
with me in peace and safety
away from all the
Wangdoodles and Hornswagglers
and Snozzwangers and
rotten Vermicious Knids.
- Snozzwangers, Vermicious Knids?
What kind of rubbish is that?
- I'm sorry but all questions
must be submitted in writing.
And so in the greatest of secrecy
I transported the entire
population of Oompa Loompas
to my factory here.
- Okay, so what Willy
Wonka has admitted here
is a huge immigration violation.
He says that he secretly
transported the entire population
of a separate country, of
Loompaland to his factory.
A lot of problems here.
Number one, I don't see any reasonable way
he could have transported
an entire country
legally through immigration channels.
On the other hand it sounds like
the Oompa Loompas were really
facing quite a hardship
in their native country.
So conceivably they
could have been refugees
seeking asylum in the
United States or the U.K.
Which actually might have
allowed it to go through.
But I don't get the sense from Willy Wonka
that he went through the proper channels
for an asylum claim either.
Additionally it sounds like he made
a quid pro quo deal with the Oompa Loompas
that he would transport
them from Loompaland,
which is a ridiculous sentence to say,
to his factory where
they would live and work.
And it doesn't seem like
he's paying them anything.
That seems like a clear violation
of the 13th Amendment's prohibition
against slavery and indentured servitude.
It really does sound like
he has transported these Oompa Loompas
away from a place where they were in fear
of being eaten alive every day
so that they could become
indentured slaves to his factory.
♪ I don't like the look of it ♪
- This is a kids movie right?
- Augustus sweetheart,
save some room for later.
- Oh, oh Augustus please don't do that.
My chocolate must never
be touched by human hands.
Don't do that!
Don't do that you're
contaminating my entire river.
Please I beg you, Augustus.
My chocolate!
My chocolate, my beautiful chocolate.
- [Mrs. Gloop] Don't just
stand there, do something!
- Help.
- Okay, so Augustus fell
into the chocolate river
because there was clearly no hand rail
protecting people from falling in.
OSHA or the Occupational Safety
and Health Administration
requires that there be a handrail
built to certain specifications
to protect people like
Augustus from falling in.
On top of that, Augustus
was touching a food product
with his bare, dirty hands
which hadn't even been washed
and clearly contaminating
this entire chocolate river.
- [Grandpa Joe] Don't worry,
he can't drink it all.
- In fact, if we rewind the clip
to see the entire chocolate river
we can see a number of
health and safety violations.
So if we take a look at this scene
we can see numerous health
and safety violations
that would shut this
factory down immediately.
Number one, we can see the OSHA violation
that there's no guardrail
protecting the Oompa Loompas
from falling inside.
We can also see that
none of the Oompa Loompas
are wearing hair nets.
So all of that green hair
is going to contaminate not just the river
but all the other food products as well.
At least the Oompa
Loompas are wearing gloves
so they've got that going for them.
On the other hand, Augustus Gloop
was touching the chocolate
river with his bare hands
and has contaminated everything.
- Augustus sweetheart,
save some room for later.
- On top of that, there is no segregation
between the candies that contain nuts
and the candies that don't contain nuts.
Which means that anyone could
have an allergic reaction
because of cross-contamination.
On top of that there appear
to be plants and trees
growing on the factory floor itself
in addition to probably
mold and other fungus.
So there's no way that this
factory could possibly be
sterile enough to produce
a food safe product.
So all of these violations
in and of themselves
would require the factory
to shut down immediately
because of violations of the FDA
and other health and safety statutes.
They're not making any
chocolate any time soon.
♪ Why don't you try
simply reading a book ♪
- Don't touch a thing.
(machine whistling)
- And in addition to the prior
health and safety violations
we just talked about
this room appears to have literal garbage
strewn about the entire factory floor.
♪ Oompa Loompa do ba dee dee ♪
- What's so fab about it?
- This little piece of gum
is a three course dinner.
- Bull.
- No roast beef but I haven't
got it quite right yet.
- [Violet] I don't care.
- Oh, I wouldn't do that.
I really wouldn't.
- So long as it's gum and that's for me.
- Violet, now don't
you do anything stupid.
- What's it taste like?
- Madness, it's tomato soup.
It's hot and creamy.
I can actually feel it
running down my throat.
- Stop, don't.
- It's delicious.
- [Charlie] Why doesn't
she listen to Mr. Wonka?
- Because Charlie she's a nitwit.
- This sure is great soup.
Hey, the second course is coming up.
Roast beef and a baked potato, mm.
- With sour cream?
(Mr. Beauregarde laughing)
What's for dessert, baby?
- Dessert?
Here it comes.
Blueberry pie and cream.
It's the most marvelous blueberry
pie that I've ever tasted.
- [Mr. Beauregarde] Holy Toledo
what's happening to your face?
- Cool it dad, let me finish.
- Yeah but your face is turning blue.
- [Mr. Beauregarde] Violet,
you're turning Violet, Violet.
- What are you talking about?
- I told you I hadn't
got it quite right yet.
- You can say that again.
Look what it's done to my kid.
- Always goes wrong when we
come to the desserts, always.
- Violet, what are you doing now?
You're blowing up.
- I feel funny.
- So here Violet Beauregarde
has been permanently disfigured
by being basically
turned into a blueberry.
- I got a blueberry for a daughter.
- Potentially under a negligence
or recklessness theory
Willy Wonka is on the hook
for whatever monetary damages
are attributed to being
permanently disfigured in that way.
And it might sound crazy
but there's actually a
very famous law school case
called the Hairy Hand case
where a doctor promised a normal hand
but delivered a hairy hand.
And the court had to determine
the difference in value
between a normal hand
versus an unseemingly hairy hand.
So the courts are in a position
to determine what the damages are
associated with being
turned into a blueberry.
On the other hand Willy Wonka might argue
that Violet disregarded his warnings
and literally plucked the
piece of gum out of his hand
against his warnings not to eat it.
And that might potentially work.
But the thing about products liability
is it's often strict liability.
Which means the courts don't
actually look at fault per say
they just look to causation,
did a given product cause the harm
associated with someone's damages.
So it's possible that comparative fault
won't be an issue and Willy
Wonka will be on the hook.
♪ Do be dee da ♪
- [Charlie] Help!
We're by the fan!
- [Grandpa Joe] Stay away from it Charlie,
it'll chop us to bits.
We're in trouble Charlie, I can't stop.
- [Charlie] It's pulling me in!
- Alright so it looks
like the Wonka factory
is evacuating the air directly out
into the outside environment.
And the same with the chocolate river
which looks like it was flowing
just right out into the
environment into waterways
then polluting into rivers and streams.
I probably don't need
to tell you that this
is an Environmental
Protection Agency nightmare.
Who knows what's happening
to the environment
because of the pollution that
this factory is producing?
He's likely to be fined severely
for this kind of environmental pollution.
♪ I want the works ♪
♪ I want the whole works ♪
♪ Presents and prizes ♪
♪ And sweets and surprises ♪
♪ Of all shapes and sizes ♪
♪ And now don't care how ♪
♪ I want it now ♪
♪ Don't care how ♪
- Yeah, that is manslaughter
bordering on negligent homicide.
A jury would convict
Willy Wonka like that.
Here once again Willy Wonka has taken
no precautions whatsoever
to protect people from
falling to their deaths
as a result of falling
into this equipment.
There are no guard rails, there
are no warnings whatsoever.
I don't think it would be very
difficult for a jury at all
to pin the blame on Willy Wonka
and to find that he's responsible
not just for the civil
violation of wrongful death
but also the criminal violations
of negligent homicide or manslaughter
because of his reckless conduct
and the fact that he is
knowingly putting these people
in this situation where
they can easily die.
♪ If you are wise you'll listen to me ♪
- So the factory's yours Charlie.
You can move in immediately.
- And me?
- [Willy Wonka] Absolutely.
- What happens to the rest--
- The whole family.
I want you to bring them all.
But Charlie don't forget
what happened to the man
who suddenly got everything
he always wanted.
- [Charlie] What happened?
- He lived happily ever after.
- Yeah, such a heartwarming ending.
The only problem is that
because Charlie has won this
as a result of the contest
he's gotta pay taxes on his winnings.
So while Charlie may be
very happy in the moment
he doesn't realize that
he's gonna be saddled
with a tax bill in the tens
if not hundreds of millions of dollars.
So unfortunately he's probably
gonna have to liquidate
a large portion of the Wonka factory
in order to settle up with the IRS.
- The truth is when you
get everything you want
you don't really live happily ever after.
Sorry.
So let's tally up Willy Wonka's
civil and criminal liability here.
First, Willy Wonka engaged
in numerous OSHA violations
which resulted in serious
foreseeable injury.
The workplace hazards alone
resulted in the deaths
of apparently four children.
So let's assume about $20 million
dollars per injured child.
That comes to $80 million dollars.
On top of that Willy Wonka
engaged in the illegal practice
of indentured servitude.
I'd peg those civil
violations somewhere around
five million dollars
for the Oompa Loompas.
And additionally, Willy Wonka engaged in
an illegal sweepstakes lottery
that probably cost
consumers somewhere between
$100 and $200 million dollars
in purchased chocolate
which we'll have to disgorge.
Which puts Willy Wonka's civil liability
somewhere in the neighborhood
of $235 million dollars.
- So you get nothing!
You lose!
- On the criminal side
it seems like Willy Wonka
is guilty of numerous
crimes against children
including multiple counts
of reckless endangerment.
- I feel funny.
- Numerous counts of manslaughter
and potentially negligent homicide.
- [Girl] He's blocking all the chocolate.
- I think conservatively
each of those violations
could bring with it jail
time of 20 to 30 years.
So multiplying that by the four children
that are permanently disfigured or dead
as a result of Willy Wonka's actions
I would say, conservatively
Willy Wonka's going to jail
for between 80 and 120 years.
- Good day, sir!
I said, good day!
♪ Boom ba dee doo ♪
- With sweatshop owner and
murderer W. Wonka in prison
Charlie's gonna have to ramp up
his skill set pretty quickly.
Otherwise he'll have to lay
off all the Oompa Loompas
to pay of his tax bill.
If Charlie wants to make
candy as great as Wonka's
he should probably check out
Skillshare's culinary courses,
like Lisa Long's class
on making English toffee.
And since Charlie is only 12 years old
he's going to have to learn
how to run a business on his own.
He should check out J. Hutch's class
on starting an online
business from scratch.
Skillshare is an online learning community
that has over 20,000 classes on everything
like lifestyle, design and technology.
The first 500 Legal Eagles will get
two free months of Skillshare
when you click on the link below.
The free premium membership
gives you unlimited
access to must know topics
so you can improve your
skills and learn new things.
It's like getting a
golden ticket to success
without all the child
murder and tax evasion.
So click on the link, get
two free months of Skillshare
and start learning today.
And until next time,
I'll see you in court.